(piano music ends)
- All right, I always wanna leave you
with something that hopefully
puts a smile on your face.
This is what I'm liking.
(upbeat music plays)
16-year-old Mario is a hard worker.
He's on the track and debate teams.
He tutors kids in English
and social studies.
He volunteers for the boys and girls club.
He's a role model for
kids in his community.
He's gonna be president,
I feel like one day.
He's also a stellar student,
but now he's gone and done something
no one at his school has done in 44 years.
He got a perfect score on the ACTs,
the full 36 points.
We have this remarkable high school junior
on the line right now.
Let's say hi to Mario,
who watches on NBC Chicago!
- (applause and cheers)
[Kelly Clarkson] Congratulations.
- Thank you.
- Oh my gosh,
were you freaking out when you found out
you got the perfect score?
- Yes. Yes, I did.
Um, so, when I got the perfect
score, I never expected it.
It was a, I expected like
a 32, a 34, very high score
but I did not expect 36.
And when I got it, I was like, oh my gosh.
And I was like, mother, mother.
And she was like, it's gonna be fine,
it's gonna be fine.
So, I threw my iPad downstairs
and then she saw what it actually was.
And then she was like, oh
my gosh, she was screaming
yelling up and down.
And people from my school
had the same reaction,
they were so excited for me.
Like, beyond excited for me.
People even started
calling me Mr. Thirty-Six,
and I'm like, I'm not perfect.
I'm nowhere near perfect,
I'm only human.
And, I'm only a junior,
I still have another year to go
before I even apply to colleges.
But, I know I do wanna
go to Columbia University
in New York. That's my dream school.
And, actually, this summer,
I'll be going to study in Oxford. So.
- What?
[Mario] I'll be studying neuroscience.
- Oh my gosh.
Look at you just living your best life.
You're so smart, you're brilliant.
That's amazing.
And, you know what it is.
It's not luck, man.
That's hard work.
You, you worked your tail off to do that.
That's, that's what hard work-
It pays off.
Congratulations, man.
On, on the hard work and on
just having a perfect score.
No, one's in that in 44 years, way to go.
Um, I'm liking your post
right now, right Mario?
(heart dings)
(applause)
And that's not all, man.
Our season-long partner,
Pilot pen makers of G2,
the go-to pen of "The Kelly Clarkson Show",
want to honor ultimate overachievers
just like you, sir.
So, they're gonna be writing you a check
for a thousand dollars,
how's that sound?
(cheering, applause)
- Oh my God. Thank you.
(laughs)
[Kelly Clarkson] All right, all right!
Thank you so much! Have a great afternoon!